estonia es ese país al que solo escuchas
mencionar en el festival de eurovisión y
eso si eres ese tipo de persona que ve
los festivales de eurovisión lo cierto
es que estonia es un país pionero en
muchas cosas es más lo podríamos
calificar como el silicon valley europeo
empresas como skype han nacido en este
país con solo un millón de habitantes y
todo esto pese que hace 30 años formaban
parte de la unión soviética no sólo eso
estonia tiene una situación de partida
bastante puñetera su clima es asqueroso
en invierno solamente tienen tres horas
de luz al día
además estonia tiene una crisis
demográfica perpetua y muy difícil de
resolver porque es uno de los pocos
países donde hay muchísima más población
femenina que población masculina es muy
difícil que la gente se pueda emparejar
y pueda hacer bebés con lo cual están
continuamente perdiendo población y pese
a todo esto estonia es el país más
moderno de europa es el único lugar del
mundo donde el acceso a internet está
garantizado como un derecho por la
constitución pero lo que hace que este
país entre en nuestro salón de la fama
de los países es la llamada residencia
virtual es decir cualquier persona del
mundo independientemente de donde esté
puede solicitar un permiso de residencia
y convertirse en ciudadano virtual de
estonia y qué significa esto os
preguntaréis en este vídeo os lo vamos a
explicar pero antes vamos a daros un
poquito de trasfondo histórico de este
país donde las cosas nunca han sido
fáciles
víctimas de vladimir putin en 1991
estonia se independizó de la unión
soviética también lo hicieron otros
países como ucrania o bielorrusia pero
en realidad no fue una independencia
real porque los nuevos gobiernos
democráticos mantenían a todas las
jerarquías ya todas las autoridades del
antiguo partido comunista no fue así en
estonia su primer presidente después de
la independencia mart laar creó un
gabinete de ministros con una media de
edad de 30 años y que no le debía
absolutamente nada a los antiguos
gerifaltes soviéticos
así es como estonia se abrió rápidamente
al mercado internacional y sin apenas
corrupción no solo modernizaron su
economía sino que además implementaron
un sistema de administración pública que
es único en el mundo por lo minimalista
que puede llegar a ser de hecho esa es
la palabra que define a estonia
minimalismo lo podemos ver hasta en su
bandera que si os dais cuenta es la
representación simplificada de su
paisaje tradicional
sin embargo no era suficiente a
principios de los 90 sólo la mitad de la
población estonia tenía una línea
telefónica en casa a falta de dinero
para carreteras decidieron invertir todo
lo que tenían en telecomunicaciones 15
años más tarde estonia se convertía en
el primer país donde se votaba online
sin embargo todas estas reformas no
salieron gratis durante estos 15 años de
progreso la minoría rusa que antes
dominaba la política estonia se había
quedado aislada por eso en el año 2007
el kremlin ya con vladimir putin
gobernando
el primer ciber ataque de la historia
mundial contra el gobierno de estonia
que como os hemos dicho estaba ya
completamente digitalizado así que
durante días este país se quedó
totalmente sin gobierno ni siquiera los
hospitales podían funcionar desde
entonces la otan tiene su centro de
protección contra ciberataques en
tallinn que para quien no lo sepa es la
capital de estonia sin embargo los
problemas de estonia no terminaron aquí
la crisis financiera dos años más tarde
en 2009 la crisis financiera mundial
golpeó especialmente a estonia que
estaba especialmente expuesta a las
inversiones internacionales así que el
gobierno se encontró con que de golpe y
porrazo no tenía dinero y además estaban
a punto de entrar en la eurozona sólo
tenían dos opciones o subían los
impuestos o recortaban gastos
en sólo unos meses estonia despidió a
10.000 funcionarios lo que suponía la
tercera parte de la plantilla pública
por supuesto los políticos se bajaron el
sueldo y se paralizaron todas las
inversiones del gobierno lo cierto es
que todos estos recortes llevaron a que
el pib de estonia cayera un 14% ese año
para que os hagáis una idea el de españa
en su peor momento solo llegó a caer un
36 sin embargo después de pasar este
2009 tan horrible la economía estonia
empezó a recuperarse inmediatamente
como no habían subido los impuestos y
montar negocios era algo muy sencillo
muchos de los que se habían quedado en
el paro comenzaron a montar sus propias
empresas de hecho aquí podemos ver el
gráfico del desempleo en sólo un año
estonia pasó de un 4 por ciento de paro
a un 19% sin embargo en sólo dos años
consiguieron reducirlo a la mitad algo
parecido ocurrió con los sueldos y de
hecho hoy en día alguien que está
trabajando en tallinn gana más dinero
que alguien que está trabajando en
sevilla y además encuentra trabajo más
fácilmente en una palabra estonia es un
ejemplo a tener en cuenta pero vamos a
ver dos de los aspectos clave que han
catapultado este
y administración digital estonia fue
pionera en la creación del dni
electrónico muchos países han intentado
seguir este modelo pero no ha llegado a
funcionar del todo bien tal vez sea
porque en estonia el dni electrónico
realmente tiene una utilidad por ejemplo
se puede utilizar para botar esto nos lo
va a explicar mi buen amigo david miguel
gaité que es un arquitecto español que
vive en estonia cualquier persona con
tal de disponer de un dni electrónico y
una conexión a internet sin ningún tipo
de gestión previa puede hacerlo en
cuestión de segundos desde cualquier
parte del mundo pero no sólo eso es que
el dni electrónico también te sirve para
pedir cita al médico o incluso para
pagar los impuestos presentar la
declaración de la cuenta pero la verdad
es que es un proceso bastante sencillo
que se hace a una cuestión de minutos
también porque por una parte del sistema
fiscal estonio está bastante
simplificado y por otra parte pues tiene
es el 99 por ciento de los datos
necesarios al automáticas e incluidos
pero espera que aquí llega lo bueno
porque alguno dirá bueno está muy bien
esto del gobierno electrónico pero puede
suponer una violación de mi privacidad
imaginemos que alguien de la
administración quisiera fijar nuestros
datos pues bien desde vuestro propio
panel de control en la página web del
gobierno estonio podéis ver exactamente
quién está mirando vuestros datos en qué
momento y para qué y podéis exigir una
explicación oficial pero si todo esto
fuera poco aquí llega lo que hace que
estonia entré de lleno en nuestro sunset
boulevard de los países
visados de ciudadanía virtual todos
hemos oído hablar de grandes empresas
que establecen su sede fiscal en panamá
o en luxemburgo sin embargo todo este
tipo de movimientos son prácticamente
imposibles si eres un autónomo o una
pyme rebelde sembró condiciones de
luxemburgo si quieres abrir una empresa
en luxemburgo primero tienes que ir al
notario y por el notario tienes que
esperar tres semanas para conseguir una
cita y luego tienes que pagar un montón
de dinero y hay un montón de burocracia
y novedad pues bien en estonia se dieron
cuenta de que necesitaban ciudadanos
nuevos así que en el año 2014 decidieron
ofrecer todos estos servicios de
administración pública digital a
cualquier persona del mundo sin importar
en qué parte del planeta esté y os
preguntaréis para qué sirve todo esto
por supuesto que no es el equivalente a
un visado de ciudadanía ni tampoco a un
pasaporte lo que sí que te permite por
ejemplo es abrirte una cuenta en un
banco estonio y poder hacer
transferencias internacionales estoy
seguro de que los que veáis este vídeo
desde venezuela entenderéis lo útil que
pueden ser estas cosas y es que desde
muchos países es prácticamente imposible
hacer transferencias internacionales
bien porque es ilegal o bien porque los
bancos no saben cómo hacerlo
esta tarjeta de residencia virtual te
permite poder montar una empresa en
estonia sin necesidad de papeleos ni
notarios y ya se lo que estáis pensando
alguno estonia es un paraíso fiscal
verdad pues no resulta que el impuesto
de sociedades en estonia es de un 20 por
ciento que es bastante normal de hecho
es el mismo que tienen en finlandia por
ejemplo lo que está me ofrece son
solamente dos cosas seguridad jurídica y
papeleos simples os parece un poco pues
ya llevan diez mil nuevos ciudadanos
virtuales en sólo dos años entre ellos
destacan personalidades como el
presidente de japón shinzo abe en otras
palabras
estonia ha inventado lo que podríamos
llamar la ciudadanía líquida que cada
uno pueda ser del país que quieras
y la pregunta es creéis que otros países
harán algo parecido llegará el día en el
que podamos elegir nuestra nacionalidad
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios si alguien quiere
profundizar más en este tema encontrará
varios links en la descripción si os ha
gustado este vídeo darle al like y
suscribiros al canal que como dice
alberto es gratis